okay our next speaker and our SEO
agreeable agency was from the University
of Houston Madison
he's a system scientist he's from
Bolivia but came and we worked together
and he is the source of all modeling
information and has some great
information to share with us about a
recent modeling effort he put together
using I think this is Victor Brady okay
survey data and then transforming that
through some modeling things done here
is a spider dancer morning everyone can
hop in gear I'm going to cut one here
and we turn it up perfect
once the combines was some management
practices that we're going to hear
throughout the lifecycle of their
collection and we want to see what these
management
so the end under sentence the results of
a study that we conducted to first cave
formation of the north dimension
practically nothing that you create
expressions so settlement election
voting they already we already know we
have a linearity a very important
component of egg harvesting soluble
nutrients but also at the same time
these are major contributors
readmissions for the area responsible
for around ten percent of the methane
and we cultural and main competition
results of experiments source or greener
definition of the dairy farm level after
magnetic also so that up to seventy
percent of the nitrogen excreted
continued monomer with management
practices during storage allocation and
then it has further implication because
they have why both issues for the
morning and ventilation importance which
will fund initiative in two dimensions
and so we emit politicians are very
susceptible to the management practices
inspired so it's very important to
identify which so here's a study words
person antidepressant practices then to
develop measures data and then compare
prices of farm sizes and farm site
groups and I know you relate both real
definition and way mission plan to come
above we have gotten its plasma today
experimental physical for deep south we
need two things
surgically but if it's data or surveys
enlightened more than 2000 higher from
contain we have pretty good response
rate for very different entities like
Morris understand but like I percent or
the rest Clarence Louis and ultimately
any and week first ain't that right
reasons for people on the response was
very worthwhile to all that problem and
also that weekend postcards moon
Saturday only one time we had Sarah
Tommy says that we have to follow
for time nor decade apart anyway of
eternity two main areas of higher
operations near Nunnally each that women
folk deepak provided that partisan for
groups abrasive site once many nine
thermal units because by lessons both
are in Munich mark suite 102 189 will be
a large iron from to 999 and they very
disabilities much more than thousand
employees we have we have 143 responding
responses on how to translate to the
constellation each group well pretty
good for vermin facility point one
percent or very facility population the
response that we got butter centralized
rice harvest essential medium our 2007
percent to two percent for small farms
so the results for eating Fireside Room
of the conserve the production small
transit on the graph that shows
different steps that we consider in
computer
our survey and ultimate modeling
exercise well in money our family
partner gonna focus on the group
components here today during the
nutrition critics of manure different
now I moms how money reflected Spirit
River it transported to storage how to
imported there some time processing part
in Hotlanta life and decided like asking
the difference these management tracks
included questions related to energy
function and the personal has been an
operation powder-keg missionary service
without reading in Russian so the people
part after getting on base management
presidency is modeling tools to quantify
procrastination person use life cycle
students need to get full picture of
what's happening in all this step also
we use equation for from the eyes demo
for methane nitrous oxide and we deserve
a half
finally we 109 Canaries need 3 or 7
times more iron a means of near a large
fire and the nuclear and versatility
handle a binary protein and the
reference scenario agent he was
representing the most common common
practice report inserted but also we
model a low rating that meeting and -
Ariana's very smart
another Oh so some results for the
survey management directive graphs shows
two types one year in handled by small
medium large facilities because here
majority small harvesting on our
internal volume here and our I'd
appreciate that all solid decree near
talked for like thirty facilities
responding to 38% and always
so this graph shows select here see how
is collected or what technology produce
small harm gather fingers and five
fingers on what we use at the far side
increases and you can see have years on
a week straight retired car uses oil and
the parasites completed there's a way to
write or IEP of collision endlessness we
in terms of transport after your
collection small farms mostly
transported to the lands of lyrically
multiplied long-term flourish is
starting to be more come for larger fire
and also various authorities transform
energy processing this indicates that
you know larger parks are new April
users in basically live storage
structures
okay for search we collected some
information on the type of searches that
want to use you can see that people
watching Network there's a wider variety
of sources density above the larger part
the old ran concrete and wasteland
recommendations Ardmore someone with an
application here you can see that small
firms show you service application but
are slight increases and we have
objection coming late and the
affirmative Pacific mm actually both
types of one application service
presentation they also related to
ratification I could in graphics I think
are interesting we chose the Holly
distance from our guilt they versus the
number of minutes and after that there's
increase in holiness and far-sighted
risen to a point in terms of civility
group where it starts at three so this
is it for exalt arms have more land for
annual units
which have certifications for
verification
in case you're processing only firmly
facilities reports and pristine forests
and aggression of those farms that you
can contain some of inspiration and in a
repetition
rizzoli expression what we through
presence reuse their of opportunities in
case prioritization was the x coating is
something what both well some are cease
completely jesters we can see that in
our organization we always evolving
technology and farther separating
digestate
we have a proposition apartment for
difference Navarrete 1.5 gb computer
supply gas per animal unit completed
won't be really trivia collection and
internet agree that invites a super fun
super flexy okay so now for ten part we
have these management practices up we
have be having an ink type theory so we
put it in nineteen areas table shows the
different monsters practices that we
consider each of them in the reference
monitor reveal the most common and then
we have this broken pipe we have as main
areas that we also models or for
pleasure for example here which is
people deal with these little field
versus market and illustrator people
see how that affects the transport pops
won't mention larger parts no transport
were not very important fire-roasting
only reported by printing facilities
more family particle police are they the
only inspiration and additions of
inspiration 5210 sustain but also we
want to see how suddenly joyful
expression without interpretation report
green transmission
porridge showing off the only large
larger firms physically we change the
retention tank usually nurses words were
if one thought on button here between
important hunting where one see what
happened to be considered shorter period
and also we evaluated storage with a
natural transformational pop even
without this important because it has
implications of discrimination is
natural at any party aerobic condition
courage which reduce the emissions of
enzymes in Crete and coalition
to that for ratification certification
injection of a pellet summarizes the
result for all these nine scenarios
small farms here the first three large
parts taken three and very different
results last a group of three wires you
can see that in snow tires
Raina definitions are donated mostly by
information is happening an application
ratification but as time flies increases
we saw that premier ice conditions the
more discrete form so there's a new
start and evolve or system
music where maintain happens and
forcibly communicate you know perfect
conditions for methane super so large
parts mostly definitions from storage
data economies of scale that I and the
bigger firms terms of ability to
teleport and processing where brief
estimation can be significantly reduced
the first group are mysterious and a
repetition and we can see a reduction in
booth here not always from the men
from search but also included area of
void admissions from the total
productivity but now inside like I got
to see also total integration relief
with compared to to drive iron net
emissions of search each actually
integration with volume us to Berlin and
repetition with but it could cost in
charge of repairs to consider in terms
of collection here in orange so the
originated and so illustrators and
partners are will be more efficient and
tear so lower radio transmissions here
as we included forage in the second
Airport there's methane emissions in
storage but as we reduce the retention
time from six months three months we see
a reduction in emissions in storage
sizes in authority to the driver here of
many missions but am
while it might be subjective that a
community such pertinent people to just
a burrito special income can even scale
large hire family community research in
terms of certain publication of sorry
magnification I did include my you
should here but first projection which
is ammonia amusement week at the same
time reducing injury-related potential
national solution that you have a
policeman but also with other Delta
applied increasing with direct and
Commission permutation location and the
overall effect 452 was neutral here so
we can all change intensified clinician
here
so for conclusions we know that both
iron wolf lead emissions in all times
are mostly driven by application form of
nitrous oxide then times light increases
encourage related usual information the
data of the funding identify this
content protein and Amidon in order to
mitigate the emissions and the North
addition of the critic sense for some
time so there's another strategy that we
expect considering like discovers you
know to reduce methane and also mentions
so there's different strategies here to
Windows computer in order to reduce
irritation parts so finish egg to your
day and project you wanna see more
information on this idea more efficient
or the other management practices and
bring our universe contention break the
Tetra that all are including paper ocean
currents in a collection we can write me
an email support engineer to three
two questions the person was dying to be
the same process and not the question
know the information on the ice of life
night one differentiate they from smoke
of the responsible arm so smokers
believe I'm so old as you can type some
different nail collection different
energy efficient way and then for the
false entry balance the storage was the
greatest area and you mention shooting
by covers arrows storage decreasing
solid content in there can all affect
act you guys have plans to take your
model look at that people specifically
yeah that's a good question I think
that's something that we can start
exploring that subside to be player here
yet yet we were thinking about more
independence it started to just focusing
on search okay you know we're going to
make sure that it better model I don't
like the question here
I assume the water generational
percentage
I think we're creeping up to 50% of that
or or maybe 40% of the animal very much
okay your other data guess there you go
so still not not a huge percentage of
the cows are on large facilities
permanent facilities so what did you say
20% yeah so still a lot on smaller
facility
yeah animal units are above so permanent
they definitely usually have a higher
milk production for animal any other
questions
Boston wasn't included you know that
it's depression and we get and you're
posting inner circle fertility and we do
see it we certainly see it but we didn't
have any responses so we didn't include
that part okay thanks very much